My daddy was my hero.
He was always there for me when I needed him.
He listened to me and taught me so many things,...
...but most of all, he was fun.
I know that Daddy had an important job.
He was working to change the world so everyone would love wildlife like he did.
He built a hospital to help animals...
...and he bought lots of land to give animals a safe place to live.
He took me and my brother, and my mum with him all the time.
We filmed together, caught crocodiles together, and loved being in the bush together.
I don't want daddy's passion to ever end.
I want to help endangered wildlife just like he did.
I have the best daddy in the whole world and I will miss him every day.
When I see a crocodile, I will always think of him...
...and I know that daddy made this zoo so everyone could come and learn to love all the animals.
Daddy made this place his whole life...
...and now, it's our turn to help daddy.
Thank you.